so let's talk about just a crazy story
out of Mississippi a Mississippi
Election Commissioner was caught on
Facebook I guess caught I mean I don't
know if that's even the right word
posting on Facebook that the blacks are
registering to vote and that
Mississippians need to do something
about it it's sort of implying that the
blacks in Mississippi aren't really the
Mississippians obviously this woman who
did this is white now for context
Mississippi is a state in trouble if you
look at American states ranked by Human
Development Index which is a sort of
composite statistic of life expectancy
education and per capita income
Mississippi is dead last if you look at
health care rankings Mississippi is dead
last or sometimes 48th or 49th if you
look at education rankings Mississippi
is 46th though so Mississippi is a place
with some serious problems black folks
make up a large percentage of the
Mississippi population and good for them
they're registering to vote
they're holding voter registration
drives they plan to vote so that they
can help their state improve in other
words you don't vote to ruin your state
you vote to improve your state by having
a say in what it is that who is going to
lead you and what it is that they're
going to do Jones County Election
Commissioner Gayle Harrison Welch posted
on Facebook that she's concerned that
lots of the blacks are registering to
vote that's it that's her concern
there's no caveat she says quote I'm
election so that I'm reading it as she
wrote it I'm a election commissioner in
Jones County I'm concerned about voter
registration in Mississippi the blacks
are having lots of events for voter
registration people in Mississippi have
to get involved too thank you for all
you do by the way before we get out this
this is super funny a guy named John
Welch who shares her last name and
appears to be a family member
responded to her Facebook comment by
saying quote Gail you are no longer
welcome at family reunions about 60
years ago all parts of the Welch
family faced a choice racism or
Americanism the Virginia side of the
Welch family from the Shenandoah chose
America you are plainly wrong which is
absolutely hilarious to see her family's
dirty laundry aired on Facebook but
eventually because this was a public
post on Facebook she was confronted
about her statement by the local
newspaper the Clarion Ledger and she
said quote I don't mean anything by it
I've worked hard to make sure everybody
is registered to vote black or white
everybody that's just how I am now in my
experience most people who refer to the
blacks doing something do mean something
by it that is racially tinged if not
straight-up racist and also when she
says the blacks are having lots of
events to register voters people in
Mississippi have to get involved too it
is obviously implying that she sees
black Mississippians as not really the
people of Mississippi it's the white
people in Mississippi that are really
the people of Mississippi now her other
excuse and this is crazy because it's
not an excuse her other excuse was the
message was meant to be sent as a
private message on Facebook it wasn't
meant to be public
I hate to break it to you all that means
is you had the sense to realize it
shouldn't be public it should be private
in order to avoid more scrutiny but it
doesn't make it any less racist or any
more outrageous and the real tragedy and
this is the the sort of circling around
the real tragedy is she still has this
position in Jones County in Mississippi
she said this in a state that is more
than 30 percent black and she is still
an election official in Jones County
Mississippi at least as of this morning
and if that changes I certainly let you
know but this is you know it the right
has this idea that calling someone
racist is the worst thing you can do and
they've actually weaponized claims of
racism against those who make the claims
you see this very frequently where
they've also memo almost made it taboo
they've tried to make it taboo
to claim to see racism and they very
often say that seeing racism is the
racism or seeing racism is quote playing
the race card that's like the phrase
trump derangement syndrome these are
phrases meant to just shut down debate
they say on the right that the left
wants to shut down debate when you tell
anybody who has identified an act of
racism that the problem is then
mentioning it that is a form of shutting
down debate similarly there's this
phrase you're suffering from tds trump
derangement syndrome when somebody on
the internet will make a criticism of
Donald Trump Trump supporters will pop
up and they'll say you're suffering from
Trump derangement syndrome this is a way
to just shut down the debate you're
disqualifying the person making the
criticism as just being blinded by
hatred of Trump and being unable to
speak coherently what what you're
actually doing is you're shutting down
the person and not even having to defend
against the claims that's the same type
of thing that we see with oh you've
identified racism you're the person who
is actually racist she is still an
election official in Mississippi